we had a guest canceled on us today
right before the show and there was just
not enough time to get a new guest so
what we're going to do instead it's rude
when that happens we're gonna take a few
phone calls we're gonna go to the
phone's 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 see what is
going on with people in the audience we
will start with our caller from the to15
area code caller from to15 go right
ahead
hello yes that's you hi I'm Jay I'm from
the Philadelphia area and I'm a big fan
thank you so with the recent upset with
the new progressive a lot of people I
feel like I'm really confused by this
and I just wanted your take what do you
mean comedian they I think they're
confused by this term Democratic
Socialist so you think the media is
hurting the left by using the verbage of
democratic socialists versus what we
truly are as a lot of progressives are
social democrats right if the person is
a self-described Democratic Socialist I
don't know that much about Alexandria
Acacio Cortez but if she's indeed are
you saying she's not actually a
Democratic Socialist no I think she is
one but I think the right is using the
term so fear-mongering and it's I feel
like it's gonna hurt a lot of
progressives that are going to run to
the Democratic side and do you think
that that's gonna hurt us in the midterm
election oh my god yeah so listen I mean
so the ups the upshot is the good thing
is that the term socialist is as popular
among young voters as it has been
arguably ever maybe maybe in a very long
time so on the one hand the attempt to
use socialists as an ad hominem by the
right is going to work less well than it
would have been in Prior times but I do
think it's really important and this is
a tough thing because as you know DeRay
a lot of this stuff is nuanced and
details and you very astutely pointed
out democratic socialism and social
democracy they have almost the same two
words in them but they mean two totally
very different things like I am NOT a
Democratic Socialist but I am a
supporter of social democracy I think it
is important for us to understand the
term
so that we are at least using them
accurately because there are other
candidates not Alexandria Castillo
Cortez who are being described as
Democratic Socialist when they just
straight up or not and I think that it
only allows the right to take advantage
of semantics and fear-mongering when the
left uses the wrong terms that being
said if someone's a Democratic Socialist
you've got to identify them as such yes
I completely agree and I hope a lot of
us do our homework while we get out
there and vote thank you so much thank
you really appreciate the call great to
hear from you